my name bad so yeah we're gonna say bye
to the lion and oh the door is open now
well it's oh oh it's all your fault
wasn't it don't mind if I take out that
chrome key from you
mystic guy coming out of the closet we'd
catch up everywhere
alright that was a pretty suit survive I
lost it what I don't know how I got that
I swear I have no idea did you send him
on mission no of course not I am in your
side I would never ever betray your pity
let's get that fight okay no I
what the hell are you doing that pity
don't worry about it okay just keep
going all right fine god damnit I see
what nothing the hardy Labrador is only
open only possible to open by pulling
the pin lever located in machine room
and another one I'm not writing down
this full description but you must only
pull the levers and the door will open
Gordon I must go I'm going ahead to the
laboratory and I will be waiting author
I pray they did you get that did you
write that down course nothing idiot yes
you are pity what a hero I don't mean to
me I don't know I just I'm just kidding
of course we're us alright we'll go in
here less pity I know
okay but I'm sorry don't be a are you on
your period pity no I'm not are you sure
are you a hundred bucks
this has to stop to find out okay I'm
sorry I love you in a broad way
alright well you got here to get the
Machine function you need a position the
lever down and release it lock for the
level located in half half what to give
it you need position lever down and it
would release a lot from further diver
located in the hall pull it open what I
don't really understand I don't
understand either
what the hell's I mean pull levers down
fine
I'll pull the lever like about oh they
check me
I hated me come to hell I don't know
where to go out way to go whatever
whatever
what is it going well hey be careful and
don't make no sense
I don't just pay you doesn't fight me
pity
don't look back listen to me I don't act
oh he's gone don't worry baby now we got
to pull the other level oh and then I
don't even know anymore just do
something that's spinning look at this
[ __ ]
yeah you're gonna go or what get that
overhead what I kept it safe all right
wait oh no back up but slowly Oh No
[ __ ] come on the way share market it
terrible acne get up get up get up get
up get up
hey hiya night I ain't out alright feels
good we're so screwed
goodnight what the hell do you call that
shower mode oh that scared me that's
scary
so I think it's the final faint then
it's Apollo are you there Devon I dare
ya
all right I tasted evening don't I know
he saw me god dammit
ah stop looking at me
it's about up if I lie wake up bang ha
ha ha
she's still there you [ __ ] kidding me
shut up what happened today let's go
down ahead I don't almost that it's
still there
Jesus Christ PD what the hell are you
doing I don't know but he's coming over
I don't know what to do
LAPD remember our training but we never
had a training that's the point what
point I don't know either
I think it's [ __ ] about I don't know
but be careful just be careful alright
alright I think he's leaving
don't worry pity yes because he's
leaving
alright let's not go too fast again
[ __ ] can break down just like a what
happens when I breakdance
alright let's actually wait this time I
don't want him to [ __ ] up
alright we need to find the other level
lever lever lever
I think alright it's safe Billy no it's
not safe
don't make the same mistake twice you
[ __ ] oh gee golly I mean I am your
mercy that's better
is it is it okay with you
let me check mad you have to wait I
think I think he's a pooper cuz poopers
stay forever
alright payday put me down
could be dad I tell ya alright I'm sorry
you would get a key
we got a hammer alright so I guess you
gotta go here and then there's our
librarian here identified what are you
doing Jennifer so where the F is the
other really can use the hammer he wrote
something but wait we came from here
[Music]
what what are you doing head I think I
need to Jennifer causing trouble oh boy
right there there you're sick son of a
[ __ ]
alright alright I got this like a boss
like a boss like a boss like a boss
tickler again this exciting stuff didn't
work the last time but I wouldn't do
this time I don't know I do
well done pity I'm proud of you thanks
father
but be careful they can still be there
yeah you still there
send my beasting what are you gonna do I
think the door is open but it's your car
pity
is he gone oh he's gone thank heavens
all right yes it is up and I have to I
have to leave you now pity you're on
your own
alright I'm proud of you you can do it
alright thanks father let's go to the
laboratory I entered the laboratory but
inside something felt different then the
moment I knew someone barricaded the
door behind me so the only way was far
away the father did you barricade the
door I have my suspicions
no it's no way he's too alright what is
this what is dad push me that's not car
totally not cool first year someone just
added me on their friendless I have way
too many people trying at me oh no I
won't die but is dead you don't
understand
they tell me I don't die but I die and
we die anyway wait anyway why OOP ah
[ __ ] me that freaking water monster
alright if there comes now
alright just gotta lean forward lean to
the left and you jump past it huh I made
it lovely
I'd miss a naked guy I'm just gonna read
this damnedest human body I love so much
blood I can't walk that bastard after
day well maybe he must die that would
jump on you and then I would go far away
and then left I mean that was right but
whatever
that's why how are we
hey Bom Bom okay [ __ ] it it flew kakapo
[ __ ] to prove someone like your
daughter it's okay
happens every Tuesday on the Wednesday
what the lantern is still 800 ohms
Tabish new I don't like this no man no
one goes Jeff no me no me gusta crying
babies love it my home is my own breast
this is what we do we can't really do
much else we just terrorize people and
spend your like this you like this [ __ ]
alright
nothing it's nothing yeah that's my arm
better my arm today I am out whatever I
don't know what I'm doing Oh what the
hell as opposed to happen to you and
even talk I hope you're happy I do my
line here just stopped working like that
it makes zero sense
zero - oh wait I got key holy [ __ ] does
it work here
hits the door in the hallway over this
one like a mouse Oh No
what I feel sorry for the what I've done
in my rage of the loss of loved one
these people I bet no and his Paloma
long sorry my wife my sweet daughter she
was only three too old for pedobear
could someone be heartless and cruel to
down now kill I'll know to every table
hanger legs and I will forget one did
have my power now the power will make
finally want to suffer mortal cannot
understand I do not care I don't care if
I lose my feelings for everything out
back although nothing I'm happy if I
feel anything so we got a note and
nothing else
well that's fan-fucking-tastic all
locked
where's my dancers long sorry alright
hey I totally let these up stay [ __ ]
let stupid I'm trying to make a sexy
mood here for you thanks buddy
thanks all better alright like this
should be open now oh no I don't know
what happened I'm sorry about the
microphone I'm sad a budget like a boss
better than ever Jennifer Jennifer yeah
please do something
I don't know me good stuff no me gusta
la gusta oh no he just killed me team
kill friendly fire
he should get punished why question we
always ask ourselves once in a lifetime
why does divide us my dad I would didn't
rise anymore is it over
did that finish that lovely angel what
am i did a my dad is this yeah must be
because Jesus is the father our parting
calls I am a God so what the hell is
going on why are you talking to Jay this
is my hombre what take some wine pity
it's French
that's why how's that possible wait I
mean water that's awesome I always want
to be actually now perhaps perhaps hey
pity immortal you can patch if you want
it what now like I'm right here excuse
me but hundreds - that's preposterous
makes no sense yes it makes no sense
just less than a folk is pity sorry I
remember I drinking wine this explains
everything
no doesn't really ring a bell spinning
around God captured them and gave them
an the protective some bad voice-acting
punish every sinner mm-hmm and then well
that's a really small
you're in no way you could pull that huh
indeed but some of them didn't
[Music]
all right what's to find men who God
granted him his form for a potion with
one condition
[Music]
the process will be complete only when
he kills the bandits oh no must protect
from bandits a recording wait long can
you finish soon because I don't have a
lot of time all right
it's okay if I exit here because I've
finished tomorrow okay maybe she's done
you can or must I mean itself go meet a
friend soon that thank you
finally I'm proud of you pity you made
it this far but now we have to end this
episode Jesus Christ that took forever
that girl was like Herpa derpa derpa
derpa derpa derpa and there perder there
w dirt is it finished now yeah it is
finished alright actually a really good
custom story props for ever made it
maybe I should check I feel like an
[ __ ] if I don't like it favorited
enjoyed subscribe to become a bro today
seriously why not mana and yeah that's
pretty much it
well done leha's I'll see you in cry
affair should be coming up after this
and that's it but what the hell what the
hell what the hell what the hell what
the hell what the hell what the hell
what the hell would hell would ever do
this Oh